a bunch of guests are inside the Big
Brother house for the new celebrity
edition end as Cameron Mathison found
out oh they may have some issues
somebody that you would like you really
hope kind of it's not gonna make it in
the house I thought my Rosa my
reputation precedes me the irony here is
we talked to Ross before he knew who was
going to be in the house oh my oh my
Rosa get ready for some fireworks
tonight
my strategy is simply this to have a
really good time and to win the game
being me Real Housewife Brandi Glanville
is a Big Brother UK bet again so she
comes prepared will you have oh yeah my
doctor signed off my head listen I I'm
pretty sure I'll have at least one panic
attack in there also in the house former
Cosby kid keshia knight pulliam I don't
think people are gonna even see what's
coming for oh man those are the most
dangerous toys I'm telling you right now
me me me all day I'm good 11 celebrities
are vying for the $250,000 grand prize
Sugar Ray's mark McGrath is one of them
friendships aren't coming out because a
nice love immediately out also in the
house actress Shannon Elizabeth athletes
chuck liddell and Metta World Peace and
a Miss Universe runner-up yep that
runner-up mistake I think it's gonna be
more difficult to not have my not my
phone but you know my entourage you know
the people that I wore way there my
GLAAD team oh you don't need your glam
team you're gonna need somebody to fend
you off for Mama Rosa
you
[Music]